BRADY HARAN: I'm in the middle
of London on Regent Street--
in case you couldn't tell with
all those red buses going by.
We want to talk about something
a little bit Olympics.
We're going to talk to
you about flags.
There's loads of flags up the
street there, but we want to
talk about one in particular.
It's one you don't often see at
the Games, because, well,
this country's never actually
won a medal.
But their flag?
Very mathematical.
DR. JAMES GRIME: We got chatting
about countries and
their flags and things.
And I thought, well,
what sort of maths
could we do with that?
And we could look at the
symmetry of flags and which
has the most symmetrical flag.
Then I thought, no.
I know what the most
mathematical flag is.
And this is amazing.
So Nepal, I reckon, has the most
mathematical flag-- the
country of Nepal.
Because the mathematical
construction for the flag is
actually written into
their constitution.
And I've got it here.
This is Article 5 of the Nepal
Constitution, where it
describes how to construct
the nation's flag.
Shall I read it to you?
Schedule 1, relating
to Article 5.
National flag.
A, method of making the shape
inside the border.
One, on the lower portion of a
crimson cloth, draw a line AB
of the required length
from left to right.
Two, from A draw a line AC
perpendicular to AB, making AC
equal to AB plus one third AB.
From AC, mark off D, making a
line AD equal to line AB.
Join BD.
From BD, mark off E, making
BE equal to AB.
Four, touching E, draw a line
FG starting from the point F
on line AC parallel to AB
to the right-hand side.
Mark off FG equal to AB.
Five, join CG.
I believe it is the only flag
for a country, certainly, that
isn't a square or a rectangle.
It makes it very unusual that
Nepal are bucking the trend.
They're sticking with it.
This is their flag.
And they're sticking with it.
From AB, mark off AH, making
AH equal to one
fourth of line AB.
And starting from H, draw a line
HI parallel to line AC,
touching line CG at point I. If
it was on cloth, we could
just fold it in half and
mark it, you see?
So maybe I'll do that
with the paper.
So I want to draw half
this distance.
Bisect CF at J and draw a line
JK parallel to AB, touching CG
at point K. It is not necessary
to have to measure
with your ruler.
You can follow these
instructions without any
measuring at all.
It's telling you to divide
things by half and quarters
and thirds.
And using those rules, without
measuring, we should be able
to do this.
Let L be the point where lines
JK and HI cut one another.
Nine, join JG.
10, let M be the point
where line JG
and HI cut one another.
With center M and with a
distance shortest from M to
BD, mark off--
I can't keep a straight face.
OK.
With center M and with a
distance shortest from M to
BD, mark off N to the lower
portion of line HI.
Touching M and starting from O,
a point on AC, draw a line
from left to right
parallel to AB.
With center L and radius LN,
draw a semicircle on the lower
portion and let P and Q be the
points where it touches the
line OM respectively.
With center M and radius MQ,
draw a semicircle on the lower
portion touching P and Q. With
center N and radius NM, draw
an arc touching PNQ at
R and S. Join RS.
Let T be the point where RS
and HI cut one another.
16, with center T and radius TS,
draw a semicircle on the
upper portion of PNQ, touching
it at two points.
This is what mathematics was
like in ancient times.
This is what it was like
to the Greeks.
All Greek mathematics
was like this and
written down like this.
With center T and radius TM,
draw an arc on the upper
portion of PNQ, touching
at two points.
Eight equal and similar
triangles of the moon are to
be made in the space lying
inside the semicircle of
number 16 and outside the arc of
number 17 of this schedule.
I made that bit up.
(WHISPERING) I cheated
there a little bit.
Just a little bit.
C, method of making the sun.
Bisect line AF at U and draw a
line UV parallel to line AB,
touching line BE at V.
I've gone blind.
Oh, it's all swimming now.
OK.
With center W, the point where
HI and UV cut one another, and
radius MN draw a circle.
Got to W. There isn't
any X and Z, so yes,
we're nearly there.
It took that many
letters, though.
It took nearly the
whole alphabet.
Just be glad there
aren't 27 steps.
What we would have done then.
With center W and radius
LN, draw a circle.
12 equal and similar triangles
of the sun are to be made in
the space enclosed by the
circles of number 20 and of
number 21 and with the two
apexes of two triangles
touching line HI.
D, method of making
the border.
The width of the border will be
equal to the width of TN.
This will be of deep blue color
and will be provided on
all sides of the flag.
However, on the five angles of
the flag, the external angles
will be equal to the
internal angles.
Explanation--
the lines HI, RS, FE, ED, JG,
OQ, JK, UV are imaginary.
Similarly, the external and
internal circles of the sun
and the other arcs, except
the crescent
moon, are also imaginary.
These are not shown
on the flag.
And it's as easy as it sounds.